>>> ONLY ON "CBS THIS MORNING,"
WE'RE EXCITED TO REVEAL THE NBA
IS CREATING A NEW SOCIAL JUSTICE
AWARD NAMED IN HONOR OF
BASKETBALL LEGEND KAREEM ADBUL
JABBAR.
THE ANNUAL KAREEM ADBUL JABBAR
SOCIAL JUSTICE CHAMPION AWARD
WILL GO TO A PLAYER RECOGNIZED
FOR PURSUING SOCIAL JUSTICE AND
UPHOLDING THE LEAGUE'S DECADES'
LONG VALUE OF EQUALITY, RESPECT,
AND INCLUSION.
THE PLAYER WILL CHOOSE AN
ORGANIZATION TO RECEIVE A
$100,000 DONATION FROM THE
LEAGUE.
AND IN AN EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW,
WE SPOKE WITH KAREEM ADBUL
JABBAR ABOUT HOW HE HOPES THE
AWARD WOULD ADVANCE THE COWSES
HE'S SPENT HIS ENTIRE LIFE
CHAMPIONING.
>> RIGHT HAND UP --
>> IT'S UP --
>> KAREEM ADBUL JABBAR IS KNOWN
FOR THAT ICONIC SKY HOOK.
IT PUT HIM IN THE RECORD BOOKS
WITH THE MOST POINTS SCORED IN
NBA HISTORY.
BUT IT'S HIS WORK OFF THE COURT
THAT'S BECOME HIS BIGGEST
LEGACY.
>> I'M DEFINITELY A PRODUCT OF
THE ACTIVISM THAT I SAW OTHER
ATHLETES INVOLVED IN.
>> Reporter: INSPIRED BY
ATHLETES LIKE JIM BROWN AND
MUHAMMAD ALI, ABDUL-JABBAR MADE
ACTIVISM THE MISSION OF HIS
LIFE.
YOU'RE SORT OF A DIRECT
RECIPIENT OF WHAT THEY WERE
TRYING TO DO DURING THEIR DAY
AND WHAT YOU'VE BEEN TRYING TO
DO PRACTICALLY ALL YOUR LIFE.
DO YOU SEE YOURSELF THAT WAY?
>> BILL RUSSELL COMES TO MIND
IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE, YOU KNOW, I
PLAYED BASKETBALL, AND I
FOLLOWED HIS CAREER.
MUHAMMAD ALI WAS A FRIEND OF
MINE.
AND HIS EXAMPLE HELPED ME EARLY
ON WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL.
THERE WAS SOMEONE THAT I ADMIRED
AND WHO MADE ME PROUD TO BE A
BLACK AMERICAN.
>> Reporter: IN 1967, HE
PROTESTED THE VIETNAM WAR DRAFT.
AND JUST A YEAR LATER, THE
20-YEAR-OLD DECLINED THE CHANCE
TO COMPETE AT THE 1968 OLYMPICS.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE OLYMPIC
COMMITTEE, AVERY BRUNDAGE, IS
THE SAME GUY WHO HAD REFUSED TO
LET JEWISH ATHLETES COMPETE IN
THE 1936 OLYMPICS BECAUSE HE
DIDN'T WANT TO ANNOY HITLER.
THAT WAS SOMEBODY I COULDN'T
COOPERATE WITH HIM.
>> Reporter: IT WAS THOSE GAMES
WHERE TOMMIE SMITH AND JOHN
CARLOS RAISED THEIR FISTS.
>> I WAS GLAD THAT SOMEBODY
REPRESENTED THAT ASPECT OF HOW
BLACK AMERICANS FELT ABOUT THE
OLYMPICS.
>> Reporter: ABDUL-JABBAR SAYS
THAT'S WHY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR
ATHLETES TO USE THEIR VOICE.
>> WITHOUT SOMEBODY PROVIDING
LEADERSHIP, WE'RE NOT GOING TO
HAVE ANY CHANGE.
WE WON'T BE ABLE TO REALIZE THE
NECESSARY CHANGES IF PEOPLE
DON'T GET OUT THERE AND POINT
OUT THE ISSUES AND SHOW SOME
LEADERSHIP.
>> Reporter: HE HOPES THE NBA'S
NEW KAREEM ADBUL JABBAR SOCIAL
JUSTICE CHAMPION AWARD WILL HELP
ATHLETES ADVANCE THE CAUSES THEY
CARE ABOUT.
>> I THINK THIS AWARD WILL
ENABLE THE VARIOUS GUYS ON
VARIOUS TEAMS TO START THINKING
ABOUT WHAT THEY CAN DO TO HELP
THINGS IN THEIR COMMUNITIES, AND
THEY CAN BECOME ACTIVISTS AND
PEOPLE WHO ARE LEADERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY.
>> Reporter: LEADERS LIKE LeBRON
JAMES, WHO WAS ONCE TOLD THAT
SHUT UP AND DRIBBLE.
AND COLIN KAEPERNICK WHO SOME
CRITICIZED FOR TAKING A KNEE
DURING THE NATIONAL ANTHEM IN
PROTEST OF POLICE VIOLENCE AND
RACIAL INJUSTICE.
>> FOR SOMEONE TO SAY SHUT UP
AND DRIBBLE, IT MEANS THAT THEY
CAN'T RECOGNIZE THE FACT THAT
LeBRON HAS CONCERNS, AND THOSE
CONCERNS WILL MOTIVATE HIM TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
WE ALL HAVE A RIGHT TO EXPRESS
OUR OPINIONS.
AND IN OUR COMMUNITY, IN THE
BLACK COMMUNITY, WE HAVE A DUTY
TO DEAL WITH ISSUES THAT BOTHER
US BECAUSE THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
INJUSTICE IN OUR COUNTRY THAT'S
BEEN PERPETRATED AGAINST PEOPLE
OF COLOR.
>> Reporter: THE SIX-TIME NBA
CHAPELYON WANTS THE NEW AWARD TO
HIGHLIGHT ATHLETES MAKING A
POSITIVE CHANGE BELIEVING SPORTS
BREAKS DOWN BARRIERS.
>> AFTER WE GO BACK AND FORTH
WITH ALL THE COMPETITION, WE
REALIZE WE'RE ALL TRYING TO DO
THE SAME THING AND THAT WE'RE
ALL HUMAN BEINGS WHO DESERVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A GREAT
LIFE.
AND COMPETITION ENABLES YOU TO
SEE THE COMMONALITY OF THE HUMAN
EXPERIENCE.
>> THE NBA PLANS TO ANNOUNCE THE
FIRST RECIPIENT OF THE AWARD
LATER THIS SEASON.
EACH OF THE OTHER FOUR FINALIST
WILL CHOOSE A CHARITY OR
ORGANIZATION TO RECEIVE $25,000.
>> KAREEM ADBUL JABBAR IS
AWESOME.
HE IS SO SMART AND SO
THOUGHTFUL.
>> IT'S DAYS LIKE THAT -- I LOVE
MY JOB EVERY DAY, BUT TO
INTERVIEW A CHILDHOOD IDOL --
>> YEAH.
>> I LOVE MY JOB.
>> AN IRDOL THAT DOES NOT
DISAPPOINT.
>> HE'S USED HI